it's great to welcome to the program
today Andy weir who is the New York
Times bestselling author of the Martian
and more recently Artemis which I just
finished reading enjoyed it very very
much Andy I'm so glad to have you on you
have an interesting background in that
you really started working in tech you
were a programmer very very young you
worked as a software engineer how'd you
sort of start getting into the writing
of sci-fi uh well I just always wanted
to be a writer and I was always into
sci-fi I think I don't remember town
when I didn't want to write I mean I
used to write like fan fiction for
beverly cleary novels when I was six it
wasn't very good but you know I was
writing it and as for science fiction I
think I was indoctrinated at an early
age my dad's a sci-fi dork
and he had this infinite collection of
science fiction books from his youth so
I think I was doomed to sci-fi do you
remember what the authors were from your
dad's library that sort of pulled you
into the genre absolutely my Holy
Trinity so to speak our Isaac Asimov
Robert Heinlein and our through C Clark
those are the guys that I read a whole
bunch of and then there's also you know
there's a whole collection of authors
that dad had but those are the ones that
really reached out and grabbed me that
and that those views of the future that
just seemed really cool so you started
writing the Martian which has sort of an
interesting backstory where you were
releasing it a chapter at a time for
free on your website and it sort of
accumulated this initial audience when
you were releasing a chapter at a time
were you also writing it as you went and
sort of tailoring subsequent chapters to
the reaction well I was writing it as I
went along so when I released a chapter
I didn't have anything beyond that
written but I didn't tailor it
specifically to what the audience
reacted to what I did do though was I
would correct errors that my readers
found so it was nice I had like three
thousand fact-checkers and when you say
errors do you mean area errors in the
science for example yeah yeah in the
science
math yeah and my readers our site were
you know our science dorks these are my
this is back before I hit it big and so
my my readership was a an email list of
people who were like hardcore science
dorks writing is so interesting in that
there there's such an element of sort of
I don't know if it's luck but it's
certainly timing and place I'm reading
Nassim Taleb the Black Swan and he talks
about how writing in particular is one
of those areas where we often don't
think about sort of the silent evidence
or all of the incredible writing that we
never hear about and the Martian
arguably was close to that right I mean
it was by virtue of you deciding well
I'm not publishing this thing as a book
in the traditional way I'll start
putting it online it'll build an
audience and eventually that led to you
know Matt Damon acting in a movie called
the Martian how do you feel about sort
of how much circumstance plays into the
success it's had of course I mean like
I've got impostor syndrome up the wazoo
I I don't really know what I did right I
have no idea why my story became so
popular and others didn't it it struck a
nerve in some way and I didn't do it on
purpose I mean I thought I was writing
for this tiny tiny little niche audience
of hardcore science dorks who wanted to
see the math play out but I ended up
reaching a broad audience I think it's
one thing that I did was I I
accidentally found a niche of
scientifically accurate science fiction
the the hard sci-fi there's not a lot of
that out there nowadays and so for for
the demographic that likes the that
likes the science to be realistic turns
out that demographic is bigger than we
thought and then the and also mainly
because it's it is now novel because
there's so few other writers doing it
and then the other thing I think that I
did without meaning to was I'm a fairly
optimistic guy when it comes to science
and technology in the future and how
it'll affect us I mean I honestly
believe that humanity just keeps getting
better in
better I think that if you look at any
century in history and ask yourself
whether you'd want to live there or the
century before you would prefer the
later century which is kind of my my my
back of the napkin proof that humanity's
quality of life just keeps going up and
up we just keep getting better
so lately I think that science fiction
has been kind of hijacked by this dismal
dystopian view of the future where
everything's doom and gloom and
Technology all it does is make humanity
like suffer and first off I don't
subscribe to that theory I think it's
wrong and second off that that so my my
books that have like this aspirational
view of the future where the future will
be cool are rare because of it which is
funny because they were the norm back in
the 50s and 60s and those of the books I
read growing up I mean I am from the 70s
and 80s but I read my father's science
fiction collection and so back in that
those days you know that the birth of
contemporary science fiction with like
Heinlein Asimov and Clarke they were all
like the futures were awesome it was
like ooh you know traveling to the you
know other planets and there is just
everything's awesome they sort of right
I mean arthur c clarke had a lot of
pretty dystopian stuff you know Starship
Troopers is not exactly the most
beautiful view of the future I mean III
think it depends on which novels right
yeah fair enough fair enough but even
then it's like the you know earth itself
and like in Starship Troopers it's a war
yeah but earth itself is pretty awesome
right like yeah
what new science fiction do you find I
mean the dystopian novels are pretty
popular in the last you know five eight
of science fiction is there new sci-fi
that you're enjoying these days yeah
there is like I like Peter Klein's a lot
his is his novels tend to be like less
dystopian and more like more like
smaller scale like the scope which I
which is what I like I
III don't like world cracking in half I
like oh this guy and his friends have a
problem
and if they don't solve it they'll die
but the rest of the universe isn't going
to suffer you know that's one thing that
that's another thing that kind of bugs
me in science fiction is the concept of
scale like the notion that you know if I
make an action movie just a contemporary
action movie it can be about a guy
trying to save his family from
kidnappers right and that's it that's
fine you know that the United States is
not in danger you know or the city of
Chicago is not going to sink into the
into the lake right but if you make a
science fiction movie for some reason
there's this presumption that the entire
setting has to be relying on these
actions like you're not allowed to have
a small stakes story in science fiction
the whole universe has to be about to
get destroyed or something and that bugs
me III disagree with that as well
that's where the Martian is one man's
life is at stake that's it
it's not it's not like Oh God all of
humanity would all but know one guy he's
gonna die if he doesn't do things right
now interestingly in Artemis the your
newer novel it's a little bit higher
stakes right I mean I don't want to a
little bit give them everything and I
don't know exactly what you want to say
but you did take a much higher stakes
approach than one person in Artemis I
did and to be honest that was so I
wanted to be honest a lot of that was
pressure from the publisher interested
yeah there they wanted it to be higher
stakes and that that's a that's a
continual argument um there is just a
general understanding or belief that you
know the stakes have to be inordinately
high in science fiction and I disagree
with that I just I think that if there's
a character and you like that character
you care about that character and it's
rare to see science fiction where it's
just you know a small group of people
with their small group of problems and
it's very very important to them and by
extension you as the reader but it's not
that important to the universe at large
so how does that work when when your
publisher I mean like how much do you
have written because presumably if
you've written enough that it's clear
what the stakes are going to be and
maybe as you're saying in Artemis
initially the stakes were not as high as
they ended up being your publisher comes
to you and they say yeah Andy this is
this is cool but we need it to be higher
stakes so do look don't you have to
rewrite a significant portion of your
entire book at that point well I would
except for in this case the the basic
plot flow of Artemis I gave it to them
as an outline initially I said like
here's a sequence of events and so we
kind of made those macroscopic plot
adjustments right then rather than me
writing the whole book how or let me put
it a different way
does tensions develop when there might
be an element to the story that you
think is sort of a key element that the
publisher says this has to be changed
and how do you sort of navigate that
well my editor is a really easy guy to
work with his name is Julian Padilla at
Crown and the kind of the feel of things
is it's all suggestions it's not like
he's making demands it's not like he's
saying like oh you've got a you've got
to change those changes it's not like
he's coming at me like he's my boss but
he does he does tell me he's like here
here's why I don't think this works or
here's why I think this has a problem or
here's why this here's why that and
here's what I'd like and
so yeah sometimes there is some tension
and sometimes I get frustrated because
yeah especially you know certain things
that that that they want that I don't
feel are necessary but you're gonna find
out with every every author and his
editor everywhere like so we're speaking
with Andy weir he's the New York Times
bestselling author of the Martian and
Artemis will pause our conversation with
him there and pick it up tomorrow we're
continuing our conversation with Andy
weir he's the New York Times bestselling
author of the Martian and Artemis we've
been speaking about the books the
Martian and Artemis but let's talk a
little bit about the movie the Martian
I've talked to a lot of writers who have
had work turned into movies or
television programs every single one of
their stories is drastically different
about how
and sort of what the process was so like
where were you when you found out hey
there's going to be a movie or there's
interest in making a movie here well I
mean I was at home and I mean I received
an email Fox was interested in the film
option on on the Martian which yeah and
so I passed that along to my agent and
we went through that process of signing
the contract and all that but it was it
everybody told me at that point you know
don't get excited
Studios by film options all the time it
doesn't mean they're gonna make a movie
they're just securing the rights in case
they want to make a movie right it's a
nice it's a nice tidy little sum of
money small compared to what you're
making off of the publishing so don't
get excited
but hey enjoy it you know it's it's
money coming out of left field it's good
yeah I actually interviewed Richard
Morgan about ten years ago and at that
point somebody maybe Warner Brothers had
bought an option on altered carbon and
of course three days ago it finally
became a series on Netflix so that that
how long it can take yeah that that's
called development help but it's it's
it's fine it's like it's just like an
extra little supplemental bit of money
and and you you put yourself in the
mindset of like well they're not gonna
do anything with it
they've just you know they've they
they're gonna give me money every
eighteen months or so it's basically
like they rent the option film options
are just they they expire so they have
the rights for like twelve or eighteen
months or whatever and then beyond that
they they the rights devolve back to me
and I can go sell them again when they
buy the rights that means they activate
the big expensive part of the contract
and they generally don't do that unless
they are definitely going to make a
movie right because they don't want to
spend the extra money for no reason
and so likes well this I'm getting a
call I'm sorry about that apologize I
forgot it happens to the best yeah I
forgot forgot to airplane and load the
phone apologize airplane mode now but
yeah who is actually the editor I was
taught
about we're not going out live are we
we're not live how fortunate so
eventually when does it become more real
I guess is the question well what
happens is a bit by bit the project just
kind of crawls forward at first they're
like oh hey Drew Goddard is interested
in writing and directing oh that's cool
okay it's like okay Drew Goddard wrote a
screenplay or is writing a screenplay
and it's really good and and we're we've
we've shopping it around to two leads or
we send it to Fox and Fox said like well
this is a really good screenplay but it
can't it can't work unless you get a big
leading man because it's so much time
spent with him so you're gonna need to
you know find a big lead or we're not
interested so they start shopping it out
on these Hail Mary passes to the biggest
names in Hollywood and then Matt Damon
says like yeah I'll play that role and
then suddenly everything becomes a lot
more serious like it's like oh wow we've
got a real a real genuine legitimate
name attached to this now and then and
then drew ended up leaving the project
to go work on spider-man for Sony so
then we have all we needed a director
and then Ridley Scott said he'd direct
and once you got Ridley Scott and Matt
Damon on the project then the big names
start piling in and it just started
snowballing but at any point it was
always possible that the studio could
pull the plug
they could say like yeah this is really
impressive but it's also getting really
expensive and they were worried about it
because of course their company they
want to make money they their job isn't
to make awesome movies their job is to
make profitable movies and they're like
well this is getting up over a hundred
million dollars now I mean are we gonna
make that money back and so you never
really knew until the day they started
shooting and once they started shooting
that first scene then they were on the
hook to pay all their all the talent and
that means that the cheapest path is now
to make the movie and that that's when I
could really celebrate now is it true
that you did not visit the set which was
in Budapest because at the time you you
weren't flying as I understand it right
because of a fear of
yes I still have a fear of flying I just
am flying somewhat now and then but
Budapest is really far away and I didn't
want to go and they did they yeah they
did the the studio work in Budapest and
they did the on location stuff in Wadi
Rum which is a desert in Jordan and I
didn't go to any of that I just wasn't
willing to travel that far but I did get
to meet all the cool famous people you
know I went to the premiere I there were
a bunch of marketing events and and
publicity events where I ended up with
them with with the cast and stuff so I
got I got to be starstruck and stuff
without having to go to Budapest that's
super interesting to me because I mean
in in the writing of the Martian in the
story there are definitely very sort of
if not physically certainly
psychologically claustrophobic sort of
circumstances that you put the character
into which even as someone like me who
has no problem flying that unnerved me
to some degree was that in any way was
the the sort of writing of those scenes
in that way in any way related to your
real world fear of flying well my real
world fear of flying is actually just
one part of a general anxiety disorder
that I have so what I really don't like
is not having control over my
environment in my situation yeah like I
don't like fact that you know somebody
else is flying a plane and all this
technology that was checked up on by
engineers I don't know you know is my
life good really depends on it and that
stuff makes me nervous so it's a lack of
control I think is what I'm really
afraid of it's not literally like
misunderstanding airline safety and
thinking it's likely crash or something
like that oh no no I I know very well
that I'm far more likely to die in a car
crash on my way to the airport than I am
to die on the flight right but it's just
this irrational phobia by definition
phobias are irrational and I just I
don't like that lack of control and and
so it informs my writing very
tangentially like
it's basically like Watney was in a
situation where he's um it how do I put
it he's in a lot of trouble but he's
never not in control you know he's he's
always had he always has the ability to
at least attempt to survive right
I remember that I you'll have to correct
me but I don't know if it was the Oscars
or some other prizes where'd the Martian
was in the Comedy category is that right
yeah that was the golden globes golden
um what was that that's Lauren B is odd
I mean I don't know what your reaction I
I and in thinking about it and I'll let
you kind of give your side of it since
you wrote it after all the way the
dialogue both internal and and actual
dialogue of the book were written
there's elements certainly of comedy but
it's it seemed weird to me to call it a
comedy so this was in 2016 right or the
73rd Golden Globes it was a it was
celebrating 2015 so yeah the the other
comedies were joy and the big short and
spy and trainwreck now spy and
trainwreck are both proper comedies yeah
right
those are both actual comedies joy was
was Jennifer Lawrence as the inventor
who invented that type of mop and she
you remember this movie yeah that's not
a comedy and the the big short about the
about people who made a bunch of money
off of the mortgage collapse also not a
comedy right yes so so this is this is a
common issue in the Golden Globes they
basically they want to give away they
want to give away more more more things
they want to give away more Awards so
that they can have more famous people up
on stage I think I'm not sure what's the
most difficult part of the entire movie
process is that seeing things
transformed from how you wrote them into
a screenplay that might not necessarily
reflect that is it something like you
write this thing and it gets turned into
a
and then it's nominated as a comedy
which it's not like what what element
was the most difficult for you you know
no part of it was difficult for me I
know it sounds weird but it's like yeah
the the the whole project had a charmed
existence like everything went right
every actor was Vale I mean there were a
few hiccups here and there but like for
the most part everything went right the
adaptation was very very true to the
original I have no complaints at all I
and all through the process everyone
involved kept telling me it never goes
this well don't get used to this this is
never gonna happen again
any plans for the project after Artemis
you're already working on anything I
have a couple of ideas well I mean I
have more ideas than I have lifespan to
write but I have a couple of ideas for
what I will write next and I'm kind of
narrowing it down to it to a few one of
which is a sequel to Artemis I do like
and I'm heavily leaning that way I do
like the idea of sticking around on
Artemis for a while because most people
like the book and the people who didn't
the people gave it negative reviews
still had nice still said that the
setting was really cool so I think that
says something that even the people who
hated the book loved the setting so I
think I'm onto something with the
setting and so I can I can make another
story that takes place there maybe you
went over some of those haters alright I
look forward to it we've been speaking
with Andy weir New York Times
bestselling author of the Martian also
more recently Artemis thanks so much for
talking to me really appreciate it
thanks for having me